hey everybody
sorry i'm a few minutes late
sorry i look so boring
i had um it had been my original
intention
to
[Music]
really kind of um go all
out in terms of you know getting done up
looking fancy you know i've been doing
this for a year
roughly um but
uh the day just has not
um really cooperated i've been
on the uh the edges of a migraine
for a couple hours
and unfortunately i woke up kind of in
the same situation
and i'm not and the uh the meds that i
take to stave off my migraines i'm not
supposed to take
more than once in a 24-hour period so
i'm just kind of hoping this will
subside on its own
it hasn't gotten much worse
but it is kind of it is kind of hanging
on
um so
it uh i i this might be a
annoyingly low energy
stream for me given that my initial
intention was to have this be
a celebration and i was intending to
drink
fairly unfettered i'm not gonna do that
i am legitimately just drinking water
this time
no joke no obfuscation this is just
water
uh my thoughts on yelena from black
widow well my review for black widow is
up if you go to the break room of geeks
i mean you can see them there a short
version i thought
she was uh she was one of the highlights
of the movie
yes um yeah molly i'll i'll avoid
spoilers but i think just
you know saying the name of a character
who was in all the trailers and saying
that i liked her i think i
think that's uh that's safe
we'll see sorry about the migraine yeah
thanks man oh hey meg
good to see you glad you stopped in
again sorry i'm not
i'm probably not going to be as
entertaining as i would
like to be
uh why do you say my cavity in a
high-pitched voice i don't know
it's just what feels right uh
taking i'm drinking just water as well
sure you are gozer
uh i'm surprised there's not a council
of geeks discord there
is but it's a patreon exclusive perk so
supporters of my patreon have access to
the discord it is not
um publicly accessible
so it does exist it's just
you know
i'm i i i am far from a control freak
but i
i need a little bit too much control in
my life
to uh make it an open source anybody can
join
situation
you have a migraine gets out herbal
solution as funk plays
play that funky music why boy
uh i feel you had a meltdown earlier due
to work overload so i'm kind of out of
it myself
seems to be a bit of a mood in the chat
well i don't drink so it's either milk
coffee or juice for me
hey whatever uh whatever does the trick
uh my copy of dreams of fire arrive
saturday and i really love it ah
one question how do you properly
pronounce okay so
uh first of all i'm going to correct
your spelling because you have it as
p-e-o-n-a it's p-o-e-n-a
and it's pronounced poena so
that is that is how her name is
pronounced
i don't drink water i get drunk on the
energy that spite
produces and red wine red wine's good
for you
yes yes so is chocolate
uh you hyped for loki episode six i'm
nervous about loki episode six because
this show has been designed in a way
that
almost the entire thing is going to
hinge on this on the finale
and sticking the landing and that will
always make me nervous
um because i
like to go the extreme i i hate when
things kind of set them up
set themselves up to be a game of
thrones
situation where everything's building to
the ending
and then the ending sucks and you can't
even really go back and enjoy
the older stuff because even when it was
good it was still building towards the
thing that didn't work
so i i am always going to
be nervous going into a finale that has
this much hinging on it
feeling like death all day oh i'm sorry
meg
it like it really does uh
seem to be a bit of a mood oopsie
dyslexia had apologized you do not have
to apologize for that
i mean it's an unusual name i'm not
necessarily expecting people to remember
how to spell it
um offhand
that was the week that was and we're not
yet midweek
yeah like
time is so weird right now
because um
like it seems like time is
crawling so much yet i look at the
calendar and go
how is this year more than half out a
half over
how how the f
i don't understand um
do you know if there are any youtubers
who talk about adaptations
like dalek to jubilee human nature from
the novel to the tv episode
um i'm not sure if anyone's
like done a dive into those i feel like
somebody must have
but off the top my head i'm not i'm not
sure
there will apparently be a second season
of loki is that confirmed
because somebody mentioned that in a
comment a couple weeks ago and i was
like is that because i remember them
talking about
um how it was designed in a way that
there could be a second season i do
i don't remember that ever getting
announced oh uh new
type jb lee so this is your reminder
folks super chats
is a guarantee that i will read your
comment i try and follow the
chat uh otherwise but i make no promises
uh super chat will guarantee that i will
read your comment and also
you get a heart for my appreciation
referring to your complex villain vid do
you think
nolan might uh be more conservative than
we realize because dark knight rises
feels kind of reactionary
i am not going to engage with that
question
not that i think it's that you're wrong
to ask it
um or that there's a problem necessarily
with trying to parse that
it's just for me and the way with the
way that i engage
with media
i try very hard not to
um try and psychoanalyze
the mentality and motives
of um creators especially ones who
don't really talk about that you know
when nolan talks about his movies he
he tends to focus on the
logistics on the filmmaking process
um but he doesn't talk a great deal
about
the underlying um motivations or his own
artistic drives even in terms of the
kinds of storylines
that he likes to tell now that's not to
say you can't you know
observe patterns in them because like
one of the first things i noticed
basically
uh and there's a couple of his movies i
still haven't seen but every nolan movie
i've ever seen ultimately was about
obsession
in some way so like he definitely has
things he comes back to but if you're
asking me to parse his political
stances i'm not comfortable doing that
now do i think that the batman
films that he directed overall
have a largely more conservative leaning
philosophy for their main character
at the very least if not the film as a
whole yes
i will say that but i i for one am not
going to make the leap
um that assumes that that means
that these are also the feelings and
beliefs of
christopher nolan himself i'm not
comfortable going there
but there's certainly um underlying
things within those movies specifically
but i i don't feel comfortable saying
that they are indicative of
the man's personal beliefs
um oh did i see the trailer for turning
red not only did i see the trailer for
turning red this is
pixar's next film i sent a tweet out
about this i
like the trailer was cute it was fine
honestly pixar trailers almost never
impressed me
um but i got
s stupidly excited
hearing and i identified it immediately
hearing the backstreet boys song larger
than life
because it's the best backstreet boys
song no that is not up for debate
no i will not be taking questions on
that at this time
it is a simple statement of fact and i
really did dig uh hearing that that got
me
stupid uh pumped like i haven't heard
that song for probably a decade
and that's a great song
legit uh geek filter
thank you you my friend get a heart
uh congratulations on your one year
youtube
adversary here's to many more well like
to be clear
like i've been on this platform for a
heck of a lot longer than a year
um but i have
uh been able to call this my
job for a year
which is nuts um trey oh
tracy thank you so much have a heart
have a couple of beats out of it that
that feels like a weird motion to do
that feels vaguely obscene
i'm not gonna do that again um congrats
on a gear here's too many more
no need to read the comment well too bad
i did it
thank you thank you very much uh
congrats on the one year i'm proud and
happy for you vera thank you brandon
larger than life-size queen damn right
meg
you better believe it
uh i hate brian letrell
i don't know who that is or or if i know
who that is i don't know that i know who
that
is uh geek filter
thank you again uh when your
professional anniversary yes
that that would be well no
i i don't keep correct to you so that
you'll do new super chats i
swear that's technically not true either
because professional
simply means you are being paid it
doesn't have to be your
primary or sole source of income for you
to be a professional
so i've been a professional for a while
too
i just had to be a professional who was
also holding down a day job
um
see uh pedantic
distinctions on my part
[Music]
larger than life is their best song
everybody is their best music video
um like maybe i didn't see i didn't
watch a lot of music videos so i
only kind of vaguely remember each of
those videos
but you know what i'll roll with that
sure why not i won't or rather i won't
dispute it
we'll go with that uh
i will clarify with a little extra money
in your pocket
thank you geek filter and then i got
pedantic on you anyways
i cannot stop myself it's like the mask
somebody stop me
one of the members of the backstreet
boys oh okay so i couldn't remember who
the hell the
actual members are i don't think i ever
really cared
let's see
uh i just saw my hometown is featured in
black widow
which while being cool i hate my
hometown
and hate it getting more publicity
yeah i can i can see where that would be
slightly conflicting
oh hey steven i didn't i didn't see you
popping hello
i'm grateful you've been youtubing for
as long as you have you've always got
some good things to say oh
thank you very much um geek filter
thank you again this is all you get
fair fair i feel like i feel like i was
i was
kind of milking the situation then again
like i'm not
making you they like you
you have agency these are your choices
of which i'm very appreciative you
should chuckle more often in your videos
i see the thing is like i especially the
videos on here i script
mostly these days and like
i can't i can't script a chuckle
i it just doesn't feel right it's
something that just has to happen
which is why it happens more often on
stream
than you know in the scripted stuff
i still hate scarlett johansson for her
response to being cast
as a transgender man yeah like here's
the thing
i've i've reached a point where i am
trying not to hold a grudge
about that uh it is still my number one
example for
how to point to on how to not
handle criticism of your uh
choice of roles from oppressed minority
groups
uh and it will probably always be my
go-to example of that
but uh barring something else
happening with her barring a fresher
example
i'm prepared to not hold a grudge
but i'll still point out how freaking
stupid that was
uh five of the actors from lovecraft
country have gotten emmy nominations
sadly the character you strongly
disliked was one of them figures
um interesting that it got that many
nominations considering that the
uh that the announcement that it
wouldn't get a second season recently
came down
so that was interesting uh would you
rather be tied
to it would you rather be tied to a
chair and gagged and like i feel like i
don't want to finish that sentence i
kind of want to just leave it there
[Music]
and be forced to watch all 12 seasons of
the big bang theory or all six seasons
of glee
well glee's shorter so i'll be brain
dead either way but it'll eat up
less of my time uh what the frill is
making me laugh so much the meltdown
episode had me in stitches
that ah what the fellas has like i knew
it was gonna be fun
just to revisit for escape it's it's
turned into a lot of fun just
bouncing off of um off of jesse
that's uh that's always a lot of and
like
the tangents we've we've started going
on have
really really taken on a life of their
own
at this point cara thank you
you get a heart carl watson just wanted
to mark your anniversary
i'm coming up on a year at the zoom
writing group well congratulations
uh one of the actresses uh from
post became one of the first translates
to be nominated for net for annette
for an emmy i swear to god
this is actually just water
um yeah i saw that headline renee um
i i don't uh pose yeah um i i don't
watch pose so i don't really have an
opinion beyond
it's nice to see that happen but other
than just the
the abstract that's kind of all i've got
what are your thoughts on the what if
trailer um
i'm intrigued to see the stories pan out
i hate the animation style
i'm hoping that that doesn't ding my
enjoyment
um too much but i really i
really do hate that anime it looks like
jet set radio
and i hate it for for animation like
i'll accept that for video games but i
hate that look
um and i know why it's there it's it's
this
it's this cheap middle ground between 2d
and 3d
animation which doing either one of
those
at a high level is expensive and time
consuming and doing this sort of middle
ground thing that they're doing is
cheaper and faster but i still hate it
i still really hate it i'm still gonna
watch because i'm intrigued enough by
the stories they're gonna tell
but i really hate the way it looks
scarlett johansson has become like
mickey rourke to me
i know they have amazing talent but
certain personal choices they
make make it harder to watch their films
even if it is incredible
i feel like that's fair uh
i'll be blended either way but it'll eat
up less of my time now that's a
tombstone engraving
if i ever heard one uh
speaking of bat oh sorry uh new type
jblee
heart again thank you
thank you speaking of batman how do you
feel about the concept of the bat
family is it beneficial for the
character can the concept work in live
action
film yes the bat family is beneficial
to the character actually the bat family
is core
to working with the character long term
because let's be completely honest
truly loner characters
get boring real
quick and
the way you keep a character interesting
is through their dynamics and their
characterization and their interactions
with other people
and i think that batman at his best in
the comics and in
things like the batman animated series
have done a good job of giving him
the uh sort of
projection and the demeanor
of a loner while still allowing him to
have these connections and have these
connections be
meaningful so i think there's absolutely
nothing wrong with the bat family
can the concept ever work in live action
maybe like i get that a big part of
why they um
why they steer away from it is just
batman and robin
just that movie which was unfortunately
the live action movie that leaned
the hardest into the idea of the bat
family um the sundown episode
is up for writing in me okay now that's
fair rowan when it comes to love craft
country
that episode that first episode is
absolutely phenomenal uh anyway getting
back to the
rant i was on so i i do get part of the
uh inherent hesitation just given the
track record
of films that have featured
you know robin and or batgirl
so i get the hesitation on that level
beyond that um
if i donate 50 will i also receive a
pulsating heart asking for a friend
if you request it um but okay
sorry i keep getting distracted by the
chat so the thing is it would
be difficult to
um to make it work in live action just
because of how
both closed off and complete films need
to be and feel
the nature of the bat family and the way
that it works
uh when it does work works much
better in a more serialized storytelling
medium
like comic books like an animated tv
show so it wouldn't be impossible to get
it to work
in live action but i think it would be
difficult
um and you would have to design your
batman
initially with the idea of
he's going to have some connections he's
not just going to push
everybody away um
i i think honestly my first thought was
you introduced batman alone then bring
in the bat family later i actually think
that
that'll just give people the batman and
robin vibe again so i actually think
what would be better is that is for us
to just
open a batman franchise a new batman
film franchise
with the bat family already there now
what iteration
of the bat family would work best in
live action
probably um
i would say honestly probably
have nightwing have him a
former robin now working on his own
batgirl sure um if you're going to have
a robin have it be tim drake
and maybe maybe skip robin and have it
be a bit more of these are
slightly more peripheral connections
and like you could start there and like
you could through interactions just um
just show how
these connections do matter to him
and uh even though he sort of let them
drift away from him a bit and so
you could then introduce a robin in a
follow-up film and have it make sense
because
um you could have established the
importance of that relationship
prior to that um now hold on i'm getting
texted
give me a second
sorry i have my kiddo texting me
she's currently going through um extreme
frustration around the owl house season
two
because we don't we have disney plus
now disney plus is going to be doing an
interesting thing they're going to drop
the first five episodes
um of the show which is currently airing
weekly on the disney channel
onto the app i think the 21st which is
nice i kind of like the idea of them
dropping chunks as opposed to
us having to wait until the entire
season's done but that having been said
the poor kiddo just because like while
waiting for the second season to start
she had watched
you know owl house videos on youtube
just looking at her recommendations she
keeps seeing things about the new season
and getting spoilers in the thumbnails i
feel really bad for her
um i've got a couple of super chats i
got to get to um
uh i do i don't know how to pronounce it
uh say eat site uh davido
thank you very much for the super chat
i'm sure i butchered your name but thank
you so much congratulations on your year
i love your videos thank you thank you
so much and also aaron oh
thank you very very much happy
anniversary
of no longer working in a soul-crushing
job
amen holy crap
[Laughter]
how's the weather in vermont sunny in
seattle today weather
it's it's been humid lately which is
part of what
sets off my migraines unfortunately
um but
temperature wise it's been all right
today was a little nicer it was kind of
in the 70s it was overcast though and
threatening to rain so hence uh we get
you know the um
humidity thing pronounce kate all right
kate kate devito thank you
thank you for correcting me um
i sympathize deeply with your kids owl
house grief yeah
it really does kind of suck for people
who have cut the cord
you know when it comes to these things
she sounds like a great kid i like to
think so
i'm incredibly biased though so you know
it's not hella hot here so that's nice
oh that's good because i know you you
you were stuck in the heat dome
for a bit there
sorry i had a little bit of a hanging
cuticle
uh off topic here but does anyone here
know what the mac size is for custom
emojis on youtube
i make emojis so i'm wondering uh if the
max size
is 480 by 480. um
i think the guideline size is 300 by 300
i'd have to double check but that's what
i think it
is um they're making a cruella too what
are your thoughts
still haven't seen the first one so i
have none i can't really have an opinion
on a sequel to a movie i haven't seen
now that that's an image um pirates
it's like satan's moist crevices here in
maryland
whoo hey v pretty sure the weather's
triggering your migraine i'm sure it is
that's usually what triggers them every
now and then
they happen for no reason
um but more often than not
it's weather-related
uh well if she's anything like you your
kid is probably amazing
i think that comment deserves a nod
don't you thank you ben
um yeah uh
my kid
i love the heck out of my kid and
she's uh she's a pain in my butt
but that's her job so you know
she uh she does it well and uh
approaches it with the plum
have you ever kissed a cat before yes
but uh not frequently i am mildly
allergic to cats
uh eight nominations in each emmy
category is a bit much more people to be
disappointed i guess like i don't really
care about the emmys
i never really have their their light
their trivia as far as i'm concerned
it's up there with the golden globes
although i suppose they're slightly more
respectable than the golden globes
and definitely better than the grammys
at least but
uh muppets christmas carol
should be uh acceptable to view all year
round
who says it isn't what
what fool said you cannot watch muppet
christmas carol
any damn time of the year give me their
name
give me their name
i'll straighten this out
[Laughter]
[Music]
i i don't know what that was
huh have you ever sang a lullaby before
i'm a parent so yeah
uh
[Music]
muppet christmas girl is except
year-round
yes i'm thank you for backing me up on
that meg
uh do you like the tony awards i pay
even less attention to the tony awards
than
anything else the i like i have a vague
awareness of when they happen which is
more than i have
i can say about the grammys at least but
that's only because i have friends who
care
about the tonys uh i just i don't
not that not not that it's like a case
of like say the golden globes where it's
like oh they're
stupid and pointless and like they have
no me like i don't think that i just
don't
follow broadway
like mocha lattes they're okay
i'll straighten this out
uncharacteristically
yeah it's it's straight is not um
this is not my normal path
uh i did re-watch muppet treasure island
for the first time in years recently tim
curry
is of course terrific but the film isn't
as good as it could have been
i have a soft spot for that movie
because first of all i just like pirate
movies and second of all i
have a particularly soft spot for
treasure island the story already
so like i'm not gonna say you're wrong
but i have a lot of affection for that
movie
because it's it's you know it's two
things that i love
put in the same space so
even while i can be aware there are some
things about it and like
let me let me be clear about one thing
the uh
the the native tribe depiction and gags
um
those have aged very badly
um but other than that like
it's just fun shiver my
timber shiver my soul
yo ho ho i did that first line without
the proper breath in
so really it really tapered off at the
end that
ugh if i ever gave the impression that i
can sing i just slaughtered it right
there
uh can we all take a moment to name our
muppet personas i'll go first i'm
obviously miss peggy
i
i have a strong suspicion
that i might be gonzo
except i don't know if i'm weird enough
but i think i might be too weird to be
anybody else
i'm pretty sure liz is camilla though
which might be part of why i gravitate
towards saying i'm gonzo
um
but yeah
ah i really do love the muppets
muppets are great um
you know it was a character who i i
never got
as a kid but as an adult i'm like he's
the funniest dang thing
sam the eagle i never fully appreciated
his jokes when i was young
but now it's like oh you are the best
love it oh you know who i might be
not necessarily the same vibe but in
terms of just
leaning into my own weirdness i might be
uncle deadly that could work
tim curry has played all three uh of the
famous fictional pirates silver
hook and the pirate king from penzance
of course he has
of course he has uh
i'm both statler and waldorf now that's
an accomplishment
i don't know which muppet i'd be i'll
dig into the muppets more and find out
uh oh my god i love kanto and yes you
are weird enough oh
thank you meg thank you so much
that is good to know animal is one of my
favorites animals classic
animals good stuff uh in
control
what do you do animal eat drums
ah no no no no beat drums beat drums
uh sorry
uh but i'm more uh more like rolf
ah ralph's a good call he's he's just
he's so
effortlessly cool
probably misspeak i'm loving this
conversation and the chat that's going
on right now by the way
uh have you ever seen the music video of
sam singing
jungle boogie it's a trip no
no i have not but now i want for nothing
else that's gonna be the first thing i
do when the stream's over
[Music]
what's your story idea of a doctor who
episode i don't really have one i've had
vague doctor who pitches but they
probably would work better
as either big finish audio or novels
i don't have an episode pitch in
specific
uh when my partner gets off work i'm
showing them bo burnham's inside it'll
be my third viewing i hope they like it
i showed it to liz she liked it for
about the first hour then she kind of
felt it went up its own ass
uh in the in the latter bit
which i can't
really dispute like it did in a way that
worked for me because it was
kind of a commentary on itself but like
i can't say it wasn't a little bit
pretentious
do you know davis the who tuber
i'm familiar with he made a video
ranking which muppets he think he could
beat in a
fight
see now i'm like
can i line up um you're probably fozzie
car
that's that's a fair one um you know can
i line up
what what muppet could i pick that would
just take him down to me well sweetums
i just booked sweetums in the fight and
he'd be done
have you seen the video of the muppet
singing bohemian rhapsody oh yeah
classic
i love beaker coming in on that for me
for
uh yeah although with beer
[Laughter]
so if it never occurred to you
in the wonderful and varied world of
burlesque and within the
subcategory of nerdlesque
that there is such a thing as
muppet themed burlesque
my friends there are such
delights i wish to share with you sadly
i don't think there's video of this
but there was a duet number that two
friends of mine
uh jinjo lolly and um
alexa luthor would do together as
bunsen honeydew and beaker
it's i've seen that number a couple of
times
it's amazing i
cannot hang on i need to try and see if
i can figure out
the the name of the song so at the very
least like you can look that up
[Music]
um
uh so but it's it's just
absolutely ridiculous
um give me one second here
is that the one oh i'm
no ah
cannot remember ah
anyways it there's this song that
it just kind of bounces and somebody
going
me me me me me and like they're
obviously singing about themselves but
it is high pitched enough that you've
that they do it with
beaker you know
do with them
me describing it doesn't do it justice
it's amazing
i've submitted a doctor who story to big
finish it starts with
uh the sentence death wielder 7456 was
crying again i won't provide any more
context
i love that as an opening sentence uh in
the 2011 muppets movie during
both picture of my head and rainbow
connection i run i i unironically cried
rainbow connection got me uh pictures of
my head didn't but rainbow connection
yeah
yeah i did uh
when you mentioned alexa luthor my alexa
went
that command is not supportive right now
[Laughter]
uh like yeah i did feel bad for her when
when um uh
when when alexa amazon's alexa became a
thing
i love my i live my life trying to be as
cool as pepe the king prawn muppet goals
hashtag muppet gold love it
i'm not a shrimp i'm a king prong
uh i have a shirt with the swedish chef
that says
vert deferc
[Laughter]
oh oh laughing like that just maybe
lightheaded
uh that's just fun to say out loud
[Music]
am i the only one who harasses you on
these streams no you're just the one who
does it the most consistently
uh i feel bad for the tall harry muppet
who mostly chases after the car
that's sweetums that's sweetums falls on
manholes and gets dynamite dropped down
on him yeah
i like sweetums he's he's a
he's a sweetheart in traditional cara
cleans while watching streams
i'm about to do my nighttime routine oh
lovely
uh
uh will you ever do a burlesque number
with one of the hamilton songs
i doubt it um there's
enough general
i mean well first of all i don't really
have i'm not inspired to use any of them
that's the thing i really
i can't just pick a song though like
i'll make a number for that like it
either
strikes inspiration or not um
but the other thing beyond that is
there's enough of um
i don't want to have the conversation
here but there's enough of a
conversation going around
with white performers using
songs written by for performed by etc
people of color uh in burlesque that
like i'd kind of prefer
not to dip my toe into that unless i can
really make a case for what it is i'm
doing but
uh i don't think i could in the case of
hamilton and again like i don't want to
have that conversation
largely because i'm not sure i have a
position worked out
on it but like it's a thing
uh it was when animal finally got back
behind the drums and rainbow connection
that got my water works going
um i think
i think for me it was just when
everybody joined in
that yeah
yeah that's that's good stuff
uh
the first five episodes of owl house
season two are going to be on disney
plus tomorrow
is it tomorrow thought it was the 21st
did they move it up i'll check that
tomorrow
uh did you watch the muppet sitcom from
a few
years ago yes and it was great
screw everyone who said that it was bad
and screw abc for canceling it
it was great it was great from the
beginning
it was still good after the retooling
because
fans were stupidly pedantic and nitpicky
about the damn
thing it was great
i loved that show it was
so good i
i'm there are a few cancellations that
i'm bitter about i'm
bitter about that one because that's one
where like it became a
punch line like people saying oh this
new muppet series why does this exist
because it's good that's why it exists
screw all ya
thank you for the reminder carowind i
shall check the discord
said in the voice that i tend to use
when i bring up the discourse
so i should probably uh not do them the
same way
uh let's see where am i oh
that's oh no that's uh that's not where
i want to be
here we go um
congratulations on your first year as a
full-time youtuber love your content
and now i can say i finished reading
your novel yesterday oh
great job i enjoyed it very much and
hope to see more of these characters in
the future oh
that's really sweet that was from uh
claret spell
that was wonderful thank you um it
i was gonna do the whole thing i'm
mentioning that the discord is a patreon
exclusive
but perp perk
yeah but that got mentioned already
uh can you impersonate mickey mouse not
very well
mean kinda but just like in the generic
way i think most people can
i it's not it's not in my it's not a an
impression that i'd i'd
brag about being able to do because i i
don't think it's
my mickey mouse is that good have you
seen muppets now on disney plus i
haven't
um for a slightly petty reason
which is that every time i i bring it up
on disney plus they highlight the
guest appearance of rupaul and i'm very
rupauled out
and i understand that it's only gonna be
one guest appearance like in one thing
but like
for some reason just seeing that every
time i hover over it it's like i
don't wanna now um
i should give it a try though favorite
looney tunes character
i think i'm partial to daffy actually
i especially if you look at the full
scope of him
over the years because he went from
being a very bugs
style character who got away with stuff
about as much as bugs did to later
becoming
the guy who doesn't get away with it and
i get
car and karma smacks him down like i
feel like he's more malleable
and his his ability to be
a jerk and not just like in the
slightly cheeky way bugs but like a real
full-on jerk
but he isn't always that's not all he
ever is i think just
makes him more interesting and i think
they've done some of the more
interesting stuff with him
uh who was the best guest star on the
muppet show
that
so
i am ill-equipped
to answer that here's why
uh i've i really only went back and
watched i think the first
two seasons of the muppet show
so this this is going back away this was
when i had netflix
not streaming but getting the dvds
mailed
and at the
time this was before i had a kid
so like this is a while back
but the uh the habit
of getting through that was that
uh i would get stoned and watch
the muppet show so
my memories of uh
that first season of the movie show
are scattered
and there's only a handful of guests
whose appearances i remember
from that first season like there's
peter houston off who wasn't great
i think there was rita moreno she was
pretty good the one that has stuck out
most of my mind
and i think the reason it stuck in my
mind so much is because i was stoned
and it just burned into my head
was mum and shots
which if you don't know who that is this
is weird funky dance troupe
because that first season the muppets
weren't really anything yet so they had
to
take whoever they could get
[Music]
oh boy oh my god you used to get stoned
please tell more
there's not much more to tell i haven't
in a very long time and i have no desire
to restart again
um but yeah that's
that's a thing that used to happen on
occasion
i know you've definitely had
reservations about the uh
new male companion for doctor who series
11.
uh do addition to the
tardis crew beneficial
um
i just i i i really
think that current era doctor who
especially
would benefit immensely from better
focus on the characters
i feel like the primary focus has been
on story and
sadly i mean that in a strictly
narrative sense
and the characters and the
characterizations
have been um not as defined as they
should have been or took
much longer to become defined than they
should have been compounded by how many
um core characters there have been and i
was really excited by the idea that it
was just gonna be the doctor in yaz
and it would force the show to focus
in and better define and explore them as
characters and adding another body
just brings one more element that's
going to inhibit their ability to do
that
is it possible that adding another
character to the show could
benefit their characters in terms of
characterization or development
maybe but that would have to fly in the
face
of a lot of the writing up to this point
and the pattern recognition in me
is not going to assume that that will
happen
oh mum and shaun's were awesome peter
sellers in season two was also
a perfect to get yeah i'm starting to
wonder if i actually got to season two
i definitely did season one though
there's ever sweeney todd broadway
revival you should play the title role
i i i would love to play sweeney todd
like just in community theater i would
love to play sweeney todd
these are my friends
see how they listen
uh i i am planning
i want to do it this year um
i want to do a dive into the movie
version of
sweeney todd for very specific reasons
and i'm kind of excited to do it
that's going to be later in the year
though okay i'm still feeling sick
getting a bit
worse going to be an adult and rest glad
i got to hang with fellow council
members for a little bit miss you all
thank you meg thank you for stopping in
and yeah i'm gonna be wrapping it up
soon myself because while my head has
thankfully not gotten
worse it also hasn't really gotten
better so yeah this is this is
not going to go into uh into overtime on
this one
i do hope you feel better soon uh
so yeah i'm trying to think if there's
anything else really to
to bring up we've got the um
we've got the loki finale tomorrow i'm
gonna have to
uh watch that and
crank out that and then
figure out if i have an angle to tackle
an overview video from the next week i
might
might not i got to figure that out on
saturday there's actually going to be a
video
going even though it was the the title
of this live stream going in much
more deeply on um
[Music]
this having been you know a year doing
this full-time
um and there's other stuff going on this
month that i'm i'm
i'm pretty excited for i've got one that
i was gonna have it be the weekend after
this one coming i might push it back
i'm just because i haven't shot it yet
and i've got more elaborate ideas for
the shooting of that one i gotta i gotta
sort that out
um but anyways i can describe you three
words hot sexy and fine
appreciated feels like uh
an inefficient use of words because some
of those are
practically synonyms so i feel like you
you have
given a very shallow description
of me vary up the meaning of each word
find some depth i'm more than just a
pretty face
oh but i am such a pretty face
as much as i love alan rickman thank
jesus they cut
judge turpin's song from the film
version oh yeah i forget about that
because i i've never seen the full
version on stage
um but i saw a taped version that had
angela lansbury as um mrs lovett
that was a trip um yeah i forget about
that song
i thought loki was gonna be a miniseries
i mean it was pitched as one but they
they said early on that they were
um that it it
was built in a way that there could be
more and yes
carowind twitch in the morning um
10 30 yes
i'm i might push it to 11
i don't know 10 30 or 11 check the
schedule
it'll just be more hearthstone again
because i still don't have a new
computer so i'm not gonna
tempt fate by trying to play anything
else um
[Music]
uh you're not the only one here with a
pretty face
oh yeah i i have lots of lovely people
who show up regularly and i appreciate
it immensely
uh one of these days i'm gonna get my
doctor who
sweeney todd uh au idea out of my head
and actually write i
write the damn fanfic do it
do it uh
so yes i am i am going to wrap it up
because it's like slight
pulsing in the back here that i should i
should put on a
i should put on a fan and lie down
you know just uh
it's the only fan i have it's my only
fan
just i'll spend some time with that
[Music]
i love teasing that idea
um have you seen black widow i have i'll
hop on over to break room of geeks
review went up this morning anyways
so thank you everybody for tuning in and
thank you for the support
um obviously to a certain extent i mean
that
financially because this is now
how i make my living but
just watching
just being here just
letting me know you want to hear my
ridiculousness
it means a lot it really does
so thank you and please
remember that you are beautiful
you are valid and
you are loved
you are the council i only run the
meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
mckeavy